weeks after he announced his return as
Superman Henry Cavill is out of a job
but at least he seems to have gotten a
hefty severance package
well that was fun while it didn't last
as the DC extended Universe prepared the
kick off in 2013 fans learned that Henry
Cavill would be the next actor to
portray Superman he made his debut via
director Zack Snyder's Man of Steel and
for a few years he continued to feature
prominently in the new cinematic
franchise however in the wake of the
disastrous 2017 release of Justice
League he basically disappeared from the
DC EU Spotlight leading many folks to
wonder if they'd ever see him down the
cape consistently again or if Warner
Brothers wanted to take the man of
tomorrow in a New Direction a
speculation ran rampant out of the blue
Cavill got the chance to play Superman
once more in 2022's Black Adam he
appeared in an additional scene to
confront teth Adam himself seemingly
promising a Black Adam Superman Showdown
sometime in the future sadly as we now
know this isn't going to happen as the
DC shared Universe enters a reset period
Kabul has been removed from the role of
Superman going forward this is arguably
the best move for DC Studios at this
point but it's just too bad his time as
Cal L came to an end so on ceremoniously
that's cool that's a betrayal I feel
stung by that at the same time one can't
feel too bad for Henry Cavill after all
he allegedly landed quite a hefty Payday
for his brief Black Adam Cameo I have a
second chance law
I'm not gonna waste it
according to Umberto Gonzalez at the
wrap on Twitter Henry cavill's
incredibly short Superman scene in Black
Adam reportedly lined his pockets quite
nicely Gonzalez claims that Cabell
scored around 250 000 for his quick
Cameo that pales in comparison to his
payout as geralt of Rivia a lead role
he's also recently lost for Netflix is
The Witcher Cosmopolitan notes that for
the first season he was paid roughly
four hundred thousand dollars per
episode which was up to over a million
dollars per episode for season two of
course swan has to remember that these
numbers were for full episodes not a
scene that clocked in under a minute
additionally Gonzalez reveals that
Cabell was also paid for one other cameo
in a yet unreleased DC Comic space
production the controversy ridden Flash
from director Andy musketti supposedly
included a cameo by Cavill as Superman
as well this is said to have netted him
an additional 250 thousand dollars
bringing his recent DC pay up to a
staggering 500 000 in total however
unlike the Black Adam guest spots we
more than likely won't get to see
cavill's flash appearance reports
indicate that the scene involving him
wound up on The Cutting Room floor
likely due to a Superman departure well
I know you didn't bring me back because
you liked me based on these numbers it's
hard to dispute that Superman has been
an incredible Money Maker for Henry
Cavill over the years at the same time
one has to question if it was ever truly
about the money for him it's impossible
to deny how much he adores the character
as evidenced by his performances and the
way he's talked about it over the past
decade if you really want hard-hitting
proof of his love for Superman though
look no further than the Instagram post
he made to announce that his time as the
man of steel had officially come to an
end in his emotional post he wrote we
can mourn for a bit but then we must
remember Superman is still around
everything he stands for still exists in
the examples he sets for us are still
there my turn to where the cape has
passed but what Superman stands for
never will time will tell who will be
fortunate enough to play Superman next
but they clearly have some big shoes to
fill
[Music]